in Star graving mad which debuted in the
fall of 1999 Tony shaloo is a quirky
horror novelist and Neil Patrick Harris
is his phobia prone editor the two being
forced to find a way to make their
partnership click is admittedly just
another variation on The well-worn Odd
Couple theme but it works doing no small
part to the talent of the two actors and
their terrific chemistry together but
this was the era when friends was in
full swing and Seinfeld had just
finished with a historic series finale
the bar was extremely high in terms of
the ratings that were expected of a
Prime Time network sit
on top of that NBC put the show in
direct competition with the first season
of ABC's Who Wants To Be A Millionaire
which of course was becoming a
full-blown phenomenon at the time and
was going to demolish pretty much
anything that tried to take it on
needless to say Stark rving mad was
canceled after one season